hey youtubers is Charlie in Fox just
announced that the Deadpool movie is
back on that's right they greenlit the
movie again for release here at this
date they have an actor and they have a
director who are these fine people you
asked you guessed it Ryan Reynolds is
still attached as his director Tim
Miller they were two of the original
people attached to the film back when
Fox first put it into development during
2011 so here are the top eight things
about this movie to get really excited
about number eight the leak test footage
is a better trailer than a real trailer
ever would have been and it came at the
right time Deadpool is being released in
the winter but it's a comic book movie
awareness and engagement for those types
of movies peaks during the summer
particularly around Comic Con
we can thank Hall H exclusives and big
studio reveals for that it just trains
people to attach themselves to their
computers and their cell phone screens
waiting for updates lo and behold some
unofficial but very authentic seeming
Deadpool test footage starts getting
passed around Fox takes it down
guaranteeing its authenticity and
heightening demand over the course of
comic-con weekend the footage gets taken
down then re uploaded several times
eventually the original writer for the
script for the screenplay Rhett Reese
starts a Twitter campaign retweet if you
would buy a ticket to a Deadpool movie
so comic book creators like Bendis
fraction and Rob Liefeld as well as some
other big celebrities throw in their
support via Twitter and Facebook then
during the end of August everything goes
completely quiet
in reality Fox probably saw what was
happening pretty early and executives
decided to move forward it just took
this long for them to announce it just
because they were trying to get everyone
under contract again if he ever wondered
why Marvel doesn't announce all the big
movie stuff more often it's because
actors writers directors have not signed
their contracts movie studios will
typically only make big announcements
when everyone is legally bound to
complete the film at a certain time
moving on to number seven even though
the test footage was largely digital
effects the movie will mostly be
live-action that is whenever Ryan
Reynolds does not have to backflip off
of an overpass there are a lot of ways
digital effects can help a Deadpool
story you know mostly making severed
heads
the current movie culture is returning
to the familiarity of practical effects
that just means building things in real
life instead of in the computer you may
have noticed that JJ Abrams totally
trolled Zack Snyder with his Millennium
Falcon reveal underneath you can see the
old Christopher Nolan tumbler the old
Batmobile attached in a very Empire
Strikes Back way like whenever the
Millennium Falcon attached to the Star
Destroyer to hide Abraham's rather than
build everything on a green screen for
Episode seven chose to build most of the
large sets aliens and vehicles a very
wise choice in my opinion Marvel is one
exception they're actually using more
digital effects as they go on but that's
just so they can get the movies out
faster it's not necessarily a good thing
but typically the use of CG versus
practical effects just comes down to
budget and how much time you have right
now we know the movie is scheduled for
release February 2016 which gives them
till about next summer to shoot the film
for quick turn over movies like Avengers
and Deadpool like big comic book movies
they can get it out in theaters within
eight months of shooting the actors but
again that window is also very dependent
on budget bigger budgets mean you can
hire more post-production people to get
your movie out faster given Bryan
Reynolds involvement and it being an
x-men spin-off type movie I would let
their budget be between 60 and 80
million dollars especially for like a
hard-r film in order to make the budget
bigger than that
they'd have to lower the rating so that
more people would go see it like more
families and obviously we want this to
be hard our but moving on to number 6
the director Tim Miller is not just the
original director attached to the
project he's the guy at blur studios who
leaked the test footage before Comic Con
this year or at least someone who worked
for him arguably the first in a series
of long events that led to Fox pulling
the movie out of mothballs blur studios
were the people that Fox hired back in
2011 to develop the project they're
primarily known as a visual effects
studio but Miller himself has been very
lucky in all this had the public
response not been so great Fox could
have totally sued him into oblivion for
leaking that footage Fox is owned by
Rupert Murdoch who is every bit as
litigious as mr. burns on The Simpsons
clearly if he was willing to risk being
thrown in a deep dark hole he must be
really passionate about the movie which
is
and makes me really optimistic that he's
gonna do a good job there's a lot more
than that that's involved in making a
good movie way more than just the
director but he's like the one guy
everyone working on the movie goes to
for answers that's why a lot of movie
directors on big films get labeled as
glorified traffic cops it's kind of a
pejorative term so if you do know any
directors in real life and you call them
that they'll probably punch you in the
face but moving on to number 5 Ryan
Reynolds is still totally attached to
star he is not currently under contract
though but he still remains committed to
the project shooting dates and getting
him under contract just requires working
out the schedule a little bit right now
he has two movies that he's committed to
in addition to Deadpool all three of
them are scheduled for release in 2016
which means next year he is going to be
very busy of those two movies one is the
cruise - like the crude sequel which
will only require voiceover work and
that isn't half as demanding as trying
to shoot a live-action movie for six
months therefore it is totally possible
for them to shoot the Deadpool movie
with him if they did run into any
scheduling problems what they might do
is just shoot any footage with him
where he has to walk around without the
mask on and then for the remainder of
the film they just use a body double and
have him provide the dialogue whenever
his schedule permits it is a whole lot
easier to make a movie if you don't need
the actor to be on set all the time and
we have to remember that because we
Wilson pretty much wears the mask full
time if they really wanted I feel like
the Phantom would not care if he never
took the mask off Early's completely I
think a lot of Fox's interest in the
project is tied to Ryan Reynolds
involvement so as long as he stays
attached the chances of this movie
actually getting made rise exponentially
number four they already have a finished
script from the original writer Rhett
Reese no word on whether this script is
the one that they'll shoot with or if
they'll try to rewrite it they don't
have a lot of time but the mere fact
that they have a finished script is a
huge bonus and add to that the test
footage that everyone saw the one that
everyone really loved was based on parts
of that so if you like the way the test
footage played you will probably enjoy
the rest of the movie people that have
read the scripts not including me I have
not read the script based on what they
say the rest of it just includes a ton
of equally crazy action sequences
and yes it was written to be a very hard
our movie mostly for violence and gore
but also has a lot of foul-mouthed
wisecracking you guys are gonna like
this next one number three it features
several other mutants from the x-men
universe just to name a few there's wire
Ajax Sluggo garrison Kane and Daniel
Cudmore Colossus there are a couple of
deadpool specific characters too like
Vanessa Carlysle supposedly there's a
lot more to but I haven't seen the
script so this is all just based on
names that have been released Fox of
course owns the x-men so using mutants
in the movie is easy and there are many
of them
I like the implication though the
Deadpool will get to mow down some
superheroes and supervillains the
characters are mercenary
at his core so as long as the hit shows
up on someone it doesn't matter if
they're good or bad no word on who that
presumed big bad like the big film of
the movie would be but there's
Sabretooth taskmaster venom bullseye so
many more Deadpool has had a beef with
almost every character in the Marvel
Universe at some point most of those
characters are owned by other studios so
what Fox might do is just been candid a
little and use some other notable big
bat from inside the x-men franchise or
they could totally do some crazy mind
and Deadpool would end up being the
big villain himself like he'd order a
hit on himself I don't think that Fox
would do something that crazy that would
make it feel more like a Doctor Who
episode number two the official synopsis
for the character is ridiculous
huge man armed to the teeth with twin
katanas and set matching desert eagle
pistols his sarcastic wit and ever
running mouth are nearly as deadly as
his fighting prowess has the tendency to
break the fourth wall and talk to the
audience
boyishly handsome in his youth but is
presently extremely this figure with
scars over face and body and let's just
be honest Wolverine is the most popular
character that Fox owns but Ted Poole
just from reading that is hands-down the
most fun you guys are totally gonna love
this last one my number one awesome
thing about the Deadpool movie Deadpool
knows that he is a character in another
movie in the Wolverine Origins movie so
he can make fun of said movie we can all
admit Wolverine Origins was just a
little bit silly with all the screaming
at sky and the one-liners
but imagine Deadpool spending half of
his new movie making fun of it and
making fun of himself in that movie his
ability to break the fourth wall Kenneth
times be both amazing and incredibly
confusing which I feel like is part of
the fun of the character but think about
this Brian Reynolds playing Deadpool
making fun of Ryan Reynolds in Wolverine
Origins as Deadpool so big question for
you guys do you think the Deadpool
should be allowed to make fun of the
Wolverine Origins movie inside the
Deadpool movie and who do you want the
big villain to be in related news I'm
working on a Constantine video and Game
of Thrones for later today be sure to
subscribe to join the team I'll be doing
episode videos for all the comic book
shows this year and it's all gonna be a
lot of fun it'll be amazing I have seen
the first episode of all the new comic
book shows that are coming yes some are
better than others but they are all a
lot of fun so right now you can click
here for that Constantine video all of
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here for my preview for agents
of shield season 2 that's coming next
week so everybody will reconvene later
for Constantine high-fives see you soon
bye
you